and so what this is this podcast riot
not done yet I'm not even close to being
John okay I'm just gonna just I have a
comment I want to make about so far the
podcast yeah is is that it's um it
started off really sad
I'm still kind of sad about it they said
this episode yeah when you yeah yeah you
don't know what happened what happened
the beginning I'm high you know how much
it took me not to smoke weed at the
funeral oh my god I went sober you did
why did you go sober just to I feel like
maybe you could even smoke more - if I
smoked I would have like bawled my eyes
out how do you get how'd you smoke a
vape a pipe a pipe joint you smoke
everyday you seem like you smoke every
day do you use it for therapeutic
purposes or how do you perform high
though it's better it is yeah what do
you mean well let me not drag you into
not the highs from the audience you know
there laughter just like carries you
home oh how do you remember your jokes
and stuff I you actually have a better
memory on weed you do I do
yeah because Jordan Peele used to smoke
Pete pot and do sketches like like a lie
you're like you know and I'd be like on
that TV oh yeah oh [ __ ] oh really
oh yeah it goes on one time where I can
I were Jordan had like no line he was
just a waiter and some sketch and he was
so high that he had to bring in a hit a
big hit just a glass of water on a tray
yeah but he was so hot right he was just
teetering like this and we were laughing
so hard because we knew that it was a
just shatters all the crowd yeah yeah
yeah
and she was so high it was so funny but
um yeah but he can perform that way I
you can't I don't know if I can but Joe
Rogan can yeah yeah yeah I think but I
never tried [ __ ] smokes weed before
he works out yes I started doing that
you did yeah it works
me and my kettlebell very are you high
is from the beginning to the end of
night then 24/7 I mean not all the time
like when you shoot your show with Manon
and those guys are you high um sometimes
yeah yeah do they know you're high
probably yeah yeah it's so hard to the
guy the last guy that I did the guy was
with for like five years
I mean he he smoked the weight as soon
we waken big it's like from beginning
it's all day but I didn't see a
personality thing I never really noticed
so because he just went about his day I
never really thought anything of it then
no stoners are portrayed a certain way
yeah movies and TV shows to be stupid
and forgetful and idiots but you know I
I show up I seem very clear to me right
now yeah I show up to work because weed
is a met is medicine and it stabilizes
me yeah and it helps calms my anxiety
down so that I couldn't be normal with
people yeah what about like auditions
you can do it still yeah I feel loser oh
wow
you don't like you and you know all the
lines and everything like that
yeah yeah yeah oh my or sometimes I'll
improvise a little bit yeah it helps me
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
maybe I should relapse us different
getting Bobby Lee anyway down the road I
think that that's gonna be off of the
nono list because I feel like okay you
guys are still allowed to smoke as many
cigarettes as you want right anyway yeah
yeah I feel like that's just so much
like far more detrimental to your health
and like wellness compared to smoking
marijuana so it's just a matter of like
I think that Meryl if it was just
marijuana but it's a gateway it's a
gateway it's not a gateway I don't do
alcoholic so I think that the only
reason it's
Gateway's because it's been you've it's
ingrained in your mind and our society's
idea of its it's a drug drug drug so you
use that capital D word over and over
again your whole life so yeah it is a
gateway but if it's let's suppose
marijuana had always been treated like
cigarettes and you've been told oh it's
just you know recreational thing that
people do I guarantee you you wouldn't
consider it a gateway the only reason
it's a gateways because your brain is
told this drug this this is so dangerous
I wouldn't I guess you're thinking about
it no it's no it's literally it's
literally the most dangerous thing I've
ever heard in my life my face is
sweating now this right here is [ __ ]
Soviet propaganda [ __ ] can I just
say [ __ ] Steve Banta it's all the
whole thing that for instance like LSD
has a lot of anti addictive properties
right a lot of these drugs that were
considered to be terrible things have
anti addictive properties and helped
people actually get sober so you know
it's it's kind of a very gray area I
understand that but here's the thing
okay
is is that since the 12 steps were
created in 1935 in Akron Ohio right
they've had a lot of trials and errors
right and they've had you know it's it's
not as if this movement started a year
ago right so over the years millions and
millions of people have tried it in
different kinds of ways and at the end
of the day they came up with this thing
it's not because they want to be
controlling or you know or it's not a
philosophy that certain segments of the
it's believed throughout because it's
been tested okay but my question is if
it was something that was you know
established in 1935 shouldn't she didn't
something established in 1935 adjust to
something that's happening in 2017 or
all this scientific knowledge that we've
garnered over the years I've been to a
meetings and they're super religious you
could say that although God and stuff
yeah it's not about God or I don't know
so you guys do something with God
I could wait for your eulogy at your
funeral yeah yeah I mean are there more
like progressive like AAA types who are
kind of experimenting with the really
hard lines between the no no drugs and
like the other acceptable things what
they did to it in the 60s okay so in the
60s think about the drugs that were
available in the 60s okay there was no
smell weed
I don't think LSD was LSD has been
around since even before that the 40s
yeah yes so um even Bill W the founder
experimented with LSD so um you know
it's the first of all it's not gone
right like there's people so there's
some power we have to get into it then
when you're you have to understand that
when people could get into a a they've
lost everything they're generally mostly
the first hundred were people that were
on the precipice of wet brain or they
were Street walkers hobos right and they
had tried every single thing throughout
their whole life and nothing worked
okay and so the one thing that they did
try which was that first hundred which
was sitting together having a meeting
once a day right and doing these steps
right got them long-term sobriety so it
worked and the reason why it worked was
because number one well you don't have
anything and you don't you you tried to
control your drinking and it didn't work
so you're powerless right I can't do it
nothing I've done works but it's the
best way to meet other people who still
drink what do you mean right don't
people like meet their and then go off
the rails no no I don't know are they
like you and me people who relapse I've
seen that in movies though every movie
okay
so I can't do it there's nothing I've
done right so then you come to a program
like a a and they go well we have a
solution what is it well a Power greater
than yourself has to remove the
addiction right your subconscious mind
maybe whatever it might be but they call
it a higher power okay
and when you do the steps there's this
thing that happens in the beginning of
the especially in the beginning of the
big book there's the doctor's opinion
there's a doctor silkworth he's a he's
he's he specializes in alcoholism he
says what happens with people in a is
there's a psychic change you know a
spiritual awakening that happens that
they believe sometimes it's a flash of
light sometimes it's an overwhelming
feeling but the obsession becomes
removed something that you think of
every day and it comes it gets
completely removed by doing these steps
I don't know why but it happened for me
it happened for my brother right and
without it without those principles I
know for myself that if I smoke pot I'm
gonna drink I know that and I'm gonna
eventually go back to opiates and then
my life falls apart so don't that's what
I'm saying so that's why I don't do it I
know myself and I know what I would do
yeah you know and maybe a and NER only
for real chronic alcoholics but I think
that it really appeals to there are it
helps for a specific type of person
because you know like you told me that
what is it like the the success rate of
a a is really only what like at 5% 5%
actually you know city coverage general
don't worry
yeah not in just a a in recovery in
general is a five person right okay and
there are there are probably people with
a certain type of however they think is
a perfect match for the 12-step program
whereas other people who are know what I
mean
five percent is that 95 percent of
people
they either die in prison on the streets
or through some sort of medical thing
because of their drug addiction and
alcoholism 95% of alcoholics and drug
addicts that seems really high it's it's
not it's a factual thing you know I mean
dark and sad no no I'm just defending I
need to defend yeah I'm just defending
you don't have to defend it you're
you're in the top five for no edge no
here's what here's what here's what it
is though I I know but you know you know
you and I have had these conversations
before sweetie and you know I you know I
haven't I haven't been to a meeting in a
year you know and so I'm kind of a dry
drunk like I'm on the precipice of what
time to go to a meeting
maybe relapsing but so I'm trying to
hang on to whatever I have to stay sober
you know I mean so this is my last you
know I'm I'm defending the the the the
the foundations of what I learned to be
true no you know also you know if what
if we ever have these discussions about
it it's not because we're trying to like
you know real you into the dark side
it's really kind of to just understand
living with an addict at least for me
when I question things about why can't
you you know use anti addictive drugs
you know they're proven to be
scientifically anti addictive why can't
you smoke marijuana when it does this
and that these are all this is just my
questions living with a partner who's an
addict and I don't understand it so I'm
gonna have questions it's not because
I'm trying to bring you in and somehow
like live up you've made it 14 years
you'll be fine you're not gonna go back
but also yeah but I mean I'll be honest
with you when you say right when you say
yeah I'm not an alcohol I said that but
just let's just is this what I'm saying
okay you're being very combative with me
right now okay no what I'm saying is
that it there are times where it like
because of the the marijuana laws
you know how easily accessible it is
when you go to like Seattle and they
have like marijuana bars now or you
could you go to a menu and you know all
that I love to marijuana and I'd love to
do it you know I would love to go to
Colorado and own a marijuana farm it's
appealing yeah so there is a there's a
slight temptation there to go there but
I had to remind myself that see I have
self-control I don't drink I smoke I can
smell and not drink yeah yeah or not do
cocaine what you said that was like
[ __ ] cocky all right
[Music]